>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Hello,
my name is David Plylar
and I'm a music specialist
at the Library of Congress.
It is my great pleasure to be here
today with Paul Lewis, pianist,
who is playing at the library.
Mr. Lewis, you have a long and
distinguished career already
and your focus during
that time has been largely
on two composers, Beethoven
and Schubert.
Your work with Beethoven involved
recordings and performances
of all 32 piano sonatas,
as well as the concerto
and the Diabelli variations.
Can you just say a bit about
what that journey was like?
>> PAUL LEWIS: I wish I could say
something intelligent about it,
but the thing is it feels
like it's still ongoing.
It's hard to say what the journey
feels like really when you are kind
of still in the middle of it
in a sense, because it's hard
to step away from it and look at
it with some kind of detachment.
It's -- the two years I spent
with the Beethoven sonatas,
like the last two years I spent
with mature Schubert piano music,
has just been the most incredible
time really musically, you know.
I mean, this is music that I feel
it's the core of my repertoire.
I'm lucky enough to be able to spend
this time concentrating, you know,
specifically on these two composers
or to have periods where I do that.
Some people say to
me, "Don't you find
after a while you want
a bit more variety?"
But I think this is the whole point.
The range within these two
composers is really something
quite extraordinary.
And the longer you spend with them
the more you realize what they
span really.
The -- it's difficult to describe.
The longer you spend with the music
the more you realize how much you
don't know.
So, the end of this two years,
for instance now with Schubert,
it feels like I'm just
starting in a way.
I'm just sort of getting into
it in a way, after two years.
And it will feel strange to
move on and do something else.
But in another sense it's
necessary to do that as well.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Well, in --
before you did this massive
Beethoven project you had been
involved with Schubert before.
You had produced a few
recordings at that time.
So, in a sense you are kind of
living that what you just said,
that you are coming
back to it again.
How -- do you find that your playing
is informed in a different way
after that Beethoven
project, of Schubert?
>> PAUL LEWIS: I think Beethoven's
a great teacher in many ways.
Again, it's difficult
to step away from it
and see how your playing
has changed.
Only -- I don't listen
to my own recordings.
It's just too difficult to
listen to one's own recordings.
But next month I'm rerecording
the C minor Schubert sonata,
which was on my first
CD 12 years ago.
So, I did listen to that and it's
quite astonishing how much it
has changed.
You don't notice it much in the
process, but when you listen back,
yeah, lots of things have changed.
It's all about balance really, it's
all about trying to find a balance
that you think makes sense and
that you think is convincing
of all the different
elements within these pieces.
And I suppose, you know, as
you play them for years and go
through your life living with them,
that balance is constantly changing.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Almost like
a lifelong gestation process.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Exactly.
Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: That makes
me think of the, you know,
comparing Beethoven and Schubert,
contemporaries in many respects.
Almost exactly, except for
Schubert's short lifespan,
towards the ends of the lives.
Schubert is often compared to
Beethoven in ways or looking
for influences in Schubert of
Beethoven on him and other things
like that, perhaps unfairly when
he has such an individual voice
and I think I -- or maybe you
could speak to that a little bit.
What is unique about his --
say with the piano sonatas,
versus the Beethoven sonatas?
>> PAUL LEWIS: yeah, I think
it's true, the comparison
with Beethoven is often made,
but I think if you're looking
to compare Schubert with Beethoven
in that sense you have Beethoven
as the standard by which
Schubert is judged.
Schubert comes out second, not
because the music is inferior
in any way, because
it's not Beethoven,
it's completely different.
And the more time I spend with both
of these composures the more
I see the differences rather
than the similarities.
And I've always felt that
one of the big differences
between these two composures that
Beethoven often seems to resolve
in a way the end of a
great work of Beethoven.
You feel that you've
arrived somewhere.
You are at the end of a journey
that's a sense of resolution.
Whereas with Schubert
it's very rarely the case.
I don't think Schubert
tries to do that at all.
Quite often you end up
with more questions hanging
in the air than you started with.
And I think that's really
fundamental to the nature
of the music of these
two composures.
And that even for that soul reason
it's very difficult to compare them.
I think you have to judge
them by their own standards.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Well, no,
that makes sense to me.
With Schubert's publication
history, post --
or not to get into it explicitly --
many of his works were not published
in his lifetime and so, the process
of dissemination was delayed,
whereas with Beethoven it
was a different situation.
With the piano sonatas, even
into this century, you know,
you don't see them as
often on as piano recitals
as one might like to see them.
Where do you see that now in terms
of his recognition among your peers
or as pianists looking
at Schubert's work?
>> PAUL LEWIS: I think
that there's --
for sure there's been a shift
in the way we perceive
Schubert over the years.
At 100 years ago these Schubert
sonatas were still very much
neglected, they were
largely unknown.
I think it was Schnabel that brought
them into the concert hall and then
after that Alfred Brendel
later in the 60s and so on.
But even then I so -- it's
only some of the later sonatas
that really became I suppose
you could say mainstream.
A lot of the others
remained neglected.
I think it's different now.
I think we see Schubert, the
composer, in a different light.
We see that he is not this
traditional Gamucklick [phonetic
spelling] cozy composer of salon
pieces, over the, you know,
the miniatures that he wrote,
of course, still great music.
But the large scales, the
sonatas and the symphonies
and the bigger pieces of
chamber music, I just --
it's just wonderful, great music.
We see that he's in
many ways the darkness
of Schubert I think has come more
into our understanding
of him as a composer.
Perhaps there was also a time
recently where he was seen primarily
as a dark tormented composer
and I think that's come
into a different kind
of balance now.
So, yeah, 200 years later
we're still finding a way
to understand Schubert.
And it's fascinating the
way that it goes, I think.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Well, I
thought we could take a look
at a few manuscripts.
We've got a couple
of small items here.
The first being the
autographed manuscript
of Beethoven's Opus
109, E major sonata.
When one encounters -- this is my
first time seeing this manuscript
myself and it's --
there's a certain sense
in which one feels a certain --
you can see kind of the process
of composition unfolding in front
of you, literally with certain types
of amendments, edits,
things like that.
You having performed and
recorded this particular piece,
do you have any initial
reactions on seeing it?
We can take a look
at other pieces too.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I'm
just overwhelmed basically.
I saw this for the first time.
I knew I was going to see it, but
then when you see it you think,
"This is it, this is
the real thing."
There's just absolutely
astonishing really.
I mean, it comes alive.
There's such a life to it.
Which it's hard to describe and
it's hard to grasp in a way.
I just noticed here in the
first movement there was a bar
in the middle of a long line.
He appears to have added a
bar almost as an afterthought,
which changes the sense
of that line.
It's, you know, of course,
only seeing the manuscript you
would realize things like this.
It's really incredible.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: One other
thing that starts to come
up as you look are the
different types of markings,
the different sizes of, you
have your forte written out
and very clearly here
just to make sure
that you know what is
supposed to happen.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Yeah, later with -- later Beethoven
he became more and more prescriptive
in the way he wrote and what
one can easily see that here.
It's actually a lot more organized
than I thought it was going to be.
It's clearer.
Because I have some --
I've seen some manuscripts
of middle period Beethoven, which
are incredibly chaotic and they sort
of scream at you in
a way off the page.
And this somehow more detailed
and there's a clarity to this.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Now, with
this particular sonata,
it features the variation set at
the end, this is how -- this is --
maybe you're thinking of
this in relation to Schubert
where you had mentioned earlier that
Beethoven tends to take the material
and win at the end
in some way, to some.
This particular piece has
a different sort of ending
where the triumph is almost in
a return or a sense of calmness.
I don't know.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: But maybe that's an
example of just the kind of breadth
that is there in the
Beethoven sonatas.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
I think the feeling of resolution
comes out in different ways
in different periods of
Beethoven's compositions.
In the middle period,
of course, they --
you often get this sense of triumph.
In the later period I
think it's different.
There's an intimate
introspective quality to this.
But you still feel that --
especially at the end
of the variation movement
there is a sense of resolution.
You feel that it doesn't
need to carry on.
It's come to a conclusion.
Whereas many of the Schubert's
last movements one feels
that they could -- there's more
of a story sometimes to be told.
Whereas this one doesn't feel
like -- the end of 110, of course,
you have this euphoric
very emphatic ending.
And then in 111 it seems to just
rise above to a different sphere.
So, I suppose these last three
sonatas you get these three
different types of
resolving, of resolution.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: And maybe a good
example of Schubert's feeling
like it could be going on to
a different thing is it sort
of circular feeling that a major
sonata, where when it comes back
to that material, that
feeling of the beginning,
at the very end of the book.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: It almost feels
like it could start again or move
into some different territory.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah.
Well, that's -- maybe looking at
this work I believe is written
around 1820 and the
sonatas that you're playing
with as Schubert were
written around -- in 1828.
Maybe to look at a couple of other
samples here, one thing would be
to look at to segue into Liszt's
as a disseminator and champion
of both Schubert and Beethoven.
What we have here first is a just
one leaf of his transcription
of Gretchen am Spinnrade, which
was published as Schubert's opus 2.
And it's not the first
page, but it's --
>> PAUL LEWIS: No.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: It's
incredibly tidy.
>> PAUL LEWIS: That
was my reaction too.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah, yeah.
Compared to other Liszt manuscripts
it definitely has that sense
of clarity and execution.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah and
containment in a way.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah.
And I believe that this
transcription was done
in 1837 or 1838.
But, of course, the work itself
was written in the teens.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: But
Schubert as a vehicle --
I'm sorry, Liszt as a vehicle
for Schubert I think he
transcribes close to 50 of his songs
and this was one of
the more famous ones,
famous as a transcription as well.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
I think one gets a sense of Liszt's
real genuine love for Schubert,
not only with the songs, but
he also transcribed, of course,
the "Wanderer" Fantasy
as a piano concerto.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: We actually
have that too I believe.
>> PAUL LEWIS: You have that here?
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yes.
I should have thought to
have brought that out.
>> PAUL LEWIS: You
see, I've played that.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Oh, you have?
>> PAUL LEWIS: I mean, I've
played the Liszt's transcription.
It works incredibly well.
I mean, the thing about it is
that when you hear the way he
orchestrates in a way it's sort
of what you hear in
the original, you know,
it's exactly what you imagine
that the original piano what
"Wanderer" fantasy would sound
like if it were orchestrated.
It's so -- it's just very
perceptive and tastefully done.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I agree.
And that particular
piece was of, of course,
the greatest importance
to Liszt as a composer.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: From the
standpoint of what it taught him
about thematic transformation.
And one sees that in all of his many
of his works, major
works after that.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah,
that's what I should have --
next time you come we will
have to show it you for sure.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Wonderful, yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Of course,
Liszt's advocacy of Schubert,
along with the advocacy
of people like Schumann,
who I believe was the
editor for the first edition
of the three sonatas
that you are playing at.
And we have -- and we'll
have a first edition
on display tomorrow,
which will be nice.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Fantastic.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Liszt did not need
to advocate as much for Beethoven,
whose reputation was pretty
much established, however,
he had a very strong affinity for
his music, both in performance
as a pianist and as an
adaptor of his works.
And just for fun we
brought out a transcription
that Liszt did I believe in 1878.
So, quite late of Beethoven's
fourth piano concerto,
which I understand is a
particular favorite of yours.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: And, so, I thought
we could take a look at that next.
>> PAUL LEWIS: That's great.
A particular challenge.
And I think Liszt was
very incredibly generous
about all the composer's work.
I think to an extent one
doesn't normally find
with other composers of the...
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yes.
Absolutely.
Especially and sometimes that came
back to haunt him a bit in terms
of reputation, because people would
question his spending that amount
of time on these types of endeavors.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: However, many
of these are absolutely unique
and interesting and
viable performance works.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I
have not heard this one
in performance, so
I was very curious.
But one thing you'll notice as
we take a look a bit farther in,
is that the parts are divided
up amongst the two pianos.
The solo part is not there.
And it's interesting to
see how Liszt chooses
to make those divisions and
also how he chooses to write
about what one should be
listening for and playing.
It's clearly a labor of labor.
I mean, at this point, you
know, he didn't need to do it,
but it was a piece that he
cared a great deal about.
And I believe he did
this for the third,
fourth and the fifth piano concerto.
We have the fourth and the fifth.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Right.
Okay. There you have it again,
when he writes string quartets
and then indications as to
-- I mean, of course, it's --
he's transcribing it as --
from a orchestral piece
into two piano work.
But still he's constantly thinking
in terms of color and what one --
the sounds one should
be or try to be making.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Right.
And that was the process
that he used
for the Beethoven symphony
transcriptions was he was very
careful to include those
indications as to what might think
about as you're playing it in terms
of what orchestral
instruments are involved.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Can I turn the page?
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah, yeah.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Is there a way to
do it -- I'm very nervous about it.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Another
interesting thing about --
in this case, this is not as --
because it's not an original
composition there aren't as many,
you know, paced overs or crossed
out things, but you do see
that he's using different colors
and this is extremely helpful
when he's been proofing or
just to show different thoughts
at different points in time.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
I don't know this well enough.
Are there any modifications
to the text that he makes?
>> DAVID PLYLAR: From what
I can tell and, again,
my first exposure to
it was yesterday.
So, from what I can tell the types
of modifications really are more
occasional octave additions.
But the things that are
just more for color,
as opposed to texture
-- actual text changes.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: From what I
can tell, I haven't studied it,
but let's look maybe
a couple more pages.
>> PAUL LEWIS: I'm interested,
because with the Wanderer fantasy
transcription occasionally he adds a
cadenza at a cadence point.
That kind of thing.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Right.
>> PAUL LEWIS: I'm wondering
what he does in the last movement
of this with those lead ins.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I'm not sure.
But I do know that he references
that one should use the Von Bulow
credenza in the first movement.
I believe.
I think we had -- we can
-- over here's actually --
just referencing the bassoon line.
I can't quite read all
of those words, but --
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, to bring
it out against the semi-turn.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Yeah.
But he wants to make sure
that this is understood.
Now, I know you generally
just use Beethoven's credenza
in your performances of the
Beethoven's concertos that correct?
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
Where the credenza exists
I generally do play.
Yeah, yeah.
The only one I have felt strange
about in the past is
for the second concerto.
That was written much much
later and it does sound --
I mean, the big credenza
for the first Beethoven
concerto was also written later,
but that's somehow seems
to feel more integrated
into the character of the movement.
Whereas the one for the
second, for the B flat,
it feels like you're launching
into the Hammerklavier sonata
and then coming back
to something, you know.
Much earlier.
But, so, that's something I've
kind of struggled with in the past,
but I think these days I just think,
no, you just play it as it is.
You don't have to modify -- it
really I think speaks for itself.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Right, right.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Ah,
something different here.
Is this the same --
no, this is a copyist.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: That's
a copyist, yes.
And then just Liszt's corrections.
And I believe it's
referring to a different spot.
I think as we go just
a bit further is the --
-- the development.
So, this point he's
still being an advocate
for his erstwhile son in law.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely, yes.
Someone I met in Japan recently
handed me a Stenhammar cadenza
for this.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Wow.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
And various things, there's
a I think a fore credenza
for the third piano concerto.
I mean, all these absolutely --
completely forgotten [inaudible].
>> DAVID PLYLAR: That would be an
interesting compilation just to --
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: We don't have
as many composers today
retroactively writing these
credenzas for his earlier works,
but in some ways that's its own
tradition that he's a bit lost now.
But, again, I think not
often maybe as successful
as the original composers.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: A fruits.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Okay.
He did here.
Vita hold.
Okay, doesn't specify, he doesn't
write out a credenza there.
That is wonderful.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I thought maybe
just as one more manuscript
to take a look at, since
we've segued into Liszt,
just taking a look
at a late Liszt work.
Representing a wide variety
of types of pieces here.
This is something from
I believe 1872
from the third Annees de Pelerinage.
Suns lacerable variorum
[phonetic spelling]
and this is actually I believe
it's an earlier version,
it's not the same as
the published version.
But from this manuscript we have
a better sense of Liszt's process
of revision and second
thoughts, paced overs.
Even at the very opening of
the piece it's paced over.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Work in progress.
I mean, that's what
brings it to life.
You can almost see the
thoughts coming from the page.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: And again,
I think from the perspective
of posterity it was nice of Liszt to
use these different colors and to --
>> PAUL LEWIS: these are later
editions, the different colors than?
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I believe they
were there just to help to edit --
>> PAUL LEWIS: Write.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Are there any
particular late Liszt works
that you were interested in
or considering performing?
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
for my next program
after the Schubert is finished I'm
playing three late Liszt pieces
in a program with --
second half with Mussorgsky,
pictures and exhibitions.
So, before the Mussorgsky there's
Schaufloce [assumed spelling],
there's Unstern and
there's the Wagner Venetsia.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Oh, great.
>> PAUL LEWIS: so, that's
yeah, three pieces, three weird
and wonderful pieces
to precede Mussorgsky.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: that's fantastic.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
You don't have the
manuscripts for --
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I
don't have those three.
We do have the five
pieces, the late pieces --
>> PAUL LEWIS: Oh, really?
>> DAVID PLYLAR: including
Suspire and, yeah.
And we do have a few.
We have the historical
Hungarian portraits.
Some other pieces like
that are in that vein.
The Toccata, real late Toccata.
I'm trying to think
of some other ones.
Yeah, we'd be happy to let you know
exactly what we have at some point.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Wonderful.
Great.
And what one feels with the
late works it's pure expression.
It's just distilled expression
with nothing to dress it up.
And I'd be very interested to see
more of those manuscripts, because,
again, having seen some
facsimiles of earlier Liszt's,
I have the B minor sonata facsimile
at home and some things from before
that and there is a kind
of energy that comes out.
I'd be interested just to
see what kind of energy
that comes off the score
of the very late pieces.
I expect it might be very different.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: I think so.
Especially when you get
there's a piece called,
"Resignation," that we have.
So, maybe it was a
good demonstrate side.
Well, I think just to close, looking
ahead beyond some late Liszt,
Mussorgsky, what other interests --
I know that you feel that this is
a continuous journey that you're on
and so I'm assuming you're
revisiting certain works
or maybe even certain whole series
of works, but what other types
of interests do you
have for the future?
We're not going to
hold you to it, but?
>> PAUL LEWIS: No, no.
Well, the next few years, so the
Mussorgsky, late Liszt, Bach,
Puccini, coming back
to some Beethoven's.
Brahms' D minor concerto I played
for the first time at the end
of this month, which
I can hardly believe.
Yeah, so it's a mixed bag.
In the next few years I'm
also coming back to Haydn
and I'm considering maybe doing
a sort of Haydn project, because,
I mean, this wonderful
rich music and, you know,
there's a lot of Haydn which I
also feel can often be overlooked.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Absolutely.
One doesn't find it represented
in recital programs very often.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: For sure.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Maybe just one or two
of the well-known sonatas,
but outside that...
So, that's something.
I'm also considering the picking
up the Roibcur [phonetic spelling]
sonata, which of course he was one
of Liszt's favorite pupils,
died when he was in his 20s,
left just a handful of pieces.
There's the organ, there's
the great organ work,
there's this piano sonata.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Should we mention
that sonata I believe is
written just a few years
after Liszt's B minor sonata.
>> PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: It's the
work of B flat minor, I think.
>> PAUL LEWIS: that's right.
And there are similiarities
for sure.
It's about the same length.
It's a similar kind
of form that it has.
In fact, the original end
to the B minor sonata,
which was this very
strong fortissimo ending.
The Roibcur has that
and you feel it.
It's sort of modeled a little
bit on the Liszt sonata,
but with the original end.
But it's also it's very much
its own original thing as well.
And it's just a wonderfully
heartfelt work and I feel
that that clearly is something
that doesn't get played
very often and deserves to.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: One gets a
sense of, even though many
of these composers, Roibcur
aside, perhaps are well-known
to audiences generally, there's
a sense of advocacy in your work
that comes through when
you're playing, I believe,
in a sense of really communing with
the work and getting to know it
and that's something
that we definitely very much
appreciate about your work.
>> PAUL LEWIS: thank
you, thank you very much.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: So, I'd
just like to thank Paul Lewis
for coming today and
speaking with us.
And best wishes for the future.
>> PAUL LEWIS: thank
you very much, pleasure.
>> DAVID PLYLAR: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.